she's charming and a little flighty but
Luna Lovegood is one of the best
characters in Harry Potter you might
think she's just a weird Ravenclaw but
here are 10 things everyone gets wrong
about Luna Lovegood it's a charm
actually Luna Lovegood is first
introduced in Harry Potter and the order
of the Phoenix Harry can see the best
roles for the first time and she tells
him that he is just as sane as she is it
was at that moment that we fell in love
with this quirky Ravenclaw Luna Lovegood
is in the same year as Ginny Weasley her
peers call her Looney Lovegood and she
doesn't really have friends throughout
the course of the fifth book she becomes
one of Harry's closest friends she even
fights with him at the Department of
mysteries some terrible things happen to
Luna in the series but she is always so
positive - most people she seems a
little crazy but there is a lot more to
Luna than meets the eye she's more than
book smart
ravenclaw has a reputation for being
full of nerdy book smart kids but there
is a lot more to being wise and
intelligence than just studying all the
time
Luna knows there is a lot more to life
than just making good grades she values
knowledge in all its forms
Ravenclaw's also the house of creativity
that's a whole different form of
intelligence Luna is very creative it's
a trade can purchase Petronas chime in
the deathly hallows Harry Ron and
Hermione visit the Lovegood house
although Luna isn't there because she's
imprisoned at Malfoy Manor we find out
quite a bit about her harry describes
seeing a mural painted of himself Ron
Hermione Neville and Ginny he describes
her painting abilities as magical even
though the pictures don't move Luna is
super artistic she's also full of
emotional intelligence she knows exactly
what to say to people when they are
hurting she comforts Harry many times
she tells him that he will see Sirius
again Sirius
and she recognizes people by more than
just their appearance ID bill and fleurs
wedding Harry is under Polyjuice potion
so that no one will recognize him but
the disguise doesn't fool Luna at all
that's some serious talent she believes
in equality Luna Lovegood is a pureblood
not all purebloods are bad the Weasleys
and the shackle bolts are amazing people
but there are certain beliefs that all
pure Bloods have even though the
Weasleys can't afford a house-elf they
still see the creatures as lesser than
wizards they just accept that house
elves are meant to take orders Dobby is
a free Adobe has come to save Harry
Potter they're also rather cruel to the
gnomes that live in their yard but Luna
does not see the world this way not only
does she reject the idea of blood purity
she sees all creatures as worthy of
respect and deathly hallows Dobby
rescues Luna and the others from the
dungeon at Malfoy Manor she treats him
with total respect she even calls him
sir Dobby likes that very much even
though Hermione advocates for house elf
rights she still talks down to the elves
as if they're children but Luna doesn't
treat Dobby like that at all she was
always kind to Hagrid even though he is
half giant she can't even imagine
treating creatures as less than her
equal she's the real champion of
equality in the story she's the best
Quidditch announcer for the first five
books the Gryffindor Lee Jordan
announces all the Hogwarts Quidditch
matches
he's pretty hilarious but he's really
not a great announcer when you think
about it he is too biased
he talks trash about the opposing teams
and players he's accusing them of
cheating and he is always getting in
trouble by McGonagall for what he says
we can't believe he lasted a full five
years with that job after Lea leaves
Hogwarts there has to be a new announcer
and Luna takes over at that point
Luna is great because even though she
gets sidetracked she is truly neutral
now she does call out Smith for being
rude but she also says exactly what is
going on in the game we don't know if
she just doesn't care enough about
Quidditch to be biased
if she's just really good at hiding her
team spirit either way she announces a
much more unbiased game than Lee Jordan
ever did also her father runs a magazine
she definitely has some experience with
reporting we hope she continued to
announce for the game it's when she went
back to Hogwarts it would be hard to
find a neutral announcer when all the
kids are in separate houses she makes a
great date oh Slughorn the potions
master in the sixth book is one strange
fellow he plays favorites with his
students he invites the kids he thinks
are special to his [ __ ] Club Harry
really doesn't want to go to select Corn
special Christmas party but lots of
people want to go with him as his date
he just isn't interested in anyone but
Ginny so he invites Luna along as a
friend he doesn't care that being seen
with Luna Lovegood might make people
gossip he just genuinely likes her in
fact he thinks she is cool and she was a
great date when Harry invites her one of
his eyebrows is a different color from a
magical accident she asks if Harry wants
her to change her eyebrow color too what
a great date she made friends with a
vampire at this party she wasn't even
scared awesome Harry was feeling pretty
bummed when Snape implied he would make
a bad Aurora she changed the subject to
a conspiracy theory Luna made Harry
laugh so hard that his drink came out of
his nose she knew exactly how to make
him feel better
anyone that ever got a chance to date
Luna was a lucky person she knows what
people think but doesn't care this is
one of Lunas best traits Luna knows that
people think she is odd she knows that
she doesn't have friends in half-blood
Prince
Romilda vane asks Harry to sit with her
on the train she is super rude to Luna
and Neville who are considered uncool
Harry refuses when it tells him that
people expect Harry to hang out with
cool people she knows very well that she
isn't one of them but she never tries to
fit in she's just herself she puts up
with Ravenclaw's hiding her belongings
all year every year she hears people
call her loony but she just keeps on
being herself she knows that once she
gets friends who accept her as she is
those friends are the ones worth keeping
she marches to the beat of her own drum
but she is always positive it's always
good to be yours
self and not care what other people
think but it's so hard
that's why Luna is such a great role
model we should all try to have the
confidence that Luna does she knows who
she is and owns it work it girl
Luna is basically snape Lunas quirkiness
leads us to our next point Luna is
basically Snape okay we know what you're
thinking
they are totally opposites snipers mean
but hear us out there are many parallels
between Luna and Snape as well as
several other characters Harry is often
compared to his father James James had
three best friends the goofy best friend
was serious who is similar to Ron his
Brainiac friend was Remus Lupin Remus
was really good at school just like
Hermione Peter Pettigrew is an outcast
with way cooler friends just like
Neville Longbottom lily was the fiery
redheaded love interest she is a lot
like Ginny Weasley and Snape was a kid
in another house who was bullied but the
original group didn't deal with things
well James and Sirius were bullies Peter
was a coward who joined the Valda Mort
and Snape chose to be cruel because of
his bullying Harry and his friends
represent the better qualities of his
parents and their friends he is kind to
most people and doesn't pick on people
Neville is actually very brave and has a
great heart and Luna is what Snape could
have been if you chose kindness or if
James had been kinder to him Luna always
chooses kindness Snape chooses
bitterness she is strong at first you
might think that Luna is just a quiet
passive girl who lets people walk all
over her and sure she does put up with a
lot of bullying but Luna Lovegood is one
strong young woman it's obvious isn't it
we have to talk to someone who's dead
first of all she is dealt with some
major trauma in her past
when she was just 9 years old her mother
passed away and Luna was there when it
happened she acknowledges that it makes
her sad but she has become a very
skilled wish despite losing her mother
so young also she doesn't just sit back
and let things happen when it matters
she signed up for Dumbledore's Army
because she knew that unbridgeable
teacher she wanted to learn how to
defend herself and let's not forget how
she finally stood up for herself in the
last movie Harry
ignoring her when she is trying to help
him figure out the last Horcrux in a
moment that truly seems out of character
she yells at him to stop and listen to
her
he is so shocked that he does exactly
what she says Luna doesn't always stand
up for herself but when it's important
she will and people listen she was
crucial to defeating Voldemort
Voldemort's had hidden six pieces of his
soul in important objects the Deathly
Hallows was all about Harry's journey to
find these objects and destroy them that
way when he finally faced down Voldemort
the evil wizard would be mortal Harry
figured out all the Horcruxes that
Baltimore made except for one he knew it
was something important to ravenclaw
even Hermione couldn't figure it out and
she had read Hogwarts a history many
times so Harry asked his ravenclaw
friend Luna tells him about the lost
diadem of Ravenclaw another ravenclaw
brushes it off as a legend it's lost
after all but Luna knows better
she helps Harry gain an audience with
the Grey Lady the ghost of Ravenclaw 'ls
daughter Luna immediately knew what the
Horcrux had to be she shows him a
replica of it and it was because of her
kindness and friendship with a great
lady that Harry was able to get the
information he needed without Lunas help
there would have been one Horcrux left
after the battle then Voldemort would
rise to power again and we'd have the
same story all over again
everyone should be thanking Luna for her
very important role in defeating the
darkest wizard ever she is super brave
muna might be a ravenclaw but she has as
much bravery as any Gryffindor let's
think back to the end of order of the
Phoenix she goes with Harry and the
others to the Ministry of magic to find
the prophecy Luna is not the type of
person to take unnecessary risks but she
knows this is important and dangerous
she goes to help her friends she is only
a four-year student and she fights off
with Death Eaters in the Deathly Hallows
Luna is kidnapped by Death Eaters she is
in prison Dan malfoy manor with
Ollivander she's been there for months
and she is probably in terrible shape by
the time she was rescued she had been
through a lot no one would blame her if
she wanted to stay at shell cottage she
wasn't even legally an adult but Luna
was too brave to do that she went with
the others back to Hogwarts to fight in
the battle
helped Harry cast his Patronus to fight
off a horde of Dementors when he
couldn't think of a happy thought
she fought against Death Eaters she was
even one of the three girls fighting
Bellatrix Lestrange before Molly Weasley
finished her off Luna Lovegood is a lot
of things and brave is definitely one of
them
Luna is the best friend ever Harry
Potter had a lot of great friends but he
was lucky to end up with Luna Lovegood
on his friends list we should all have a
friends like Luna there were several
times when Luna comforted Harry when no
one else could after Sirius went through
the Vale she talked to him frankly about
death and reassured him she spoke at
dobby's funeral when everyone else was
too overcome by grief to do it when
Harry thought he was going crazy because
he could see fest rolls Luna reassured
him even though she was in a different
house she went all decked out in support
of her friends Quidditch team she even
made that crazy lion hat that roared to
support the Gryffindor's she told Harry
to remember that they are all still
alive and still fighting when he lost
hope during the Battle of Hogwarts and
after the battle Luna knew exactly what
he needed harry was exhausted but he was
now the savior of the Wizarding World
she knew he needed peace and quiet so
she distracted everyone and told Harry
to slip away under his invisibility
cloak we could use more people like Luna
Lovegood in the world what is your
favorite thing about Luna let us know in
the comments section that's it for the
ten things that everyone gets wrong
about Luna Lovegood get those racks
firts out of your head and subscribe to
get more magical videos
[Music]